a puntino internati eintracht horse
visto che l'altro video di gira la ruota
in cui la nota selen in crisi dello slam
di è piaciuto tantissimo ho deciso di
farne un altro però senza colla quindi
gli ingredienti che in genere si sono
per farlo senza cosa succederà
uscirà lo slime senza collo lo comunica
non ne ho idea
fatemi sapere nei commenti secondo voi
come uscirà se uscirà e di che colore
uscirà e siete pronti andremo cedere 10
ingredienti dalla ruota andremo
mischiano in tutti assieme e vediamo se
questo slime senza con le pulsazioni fu
ricostruita due razze
siete pronti se volete vedere altri
video con la ruota lasciate un pre
laiche in simil a life
andrò a fare un altro pd or collaro
diritture nei commenti le vostre idee
gli altri video che posso fare con la
ruota e ora siete pronti patatine con
corner iniziamo subito o ingrediente
hanno avuto seri e ben 10 numero a cuneo
crediamo proprio capito dio con un po di
paura che se no in pratica perché quello
duro miss che con le mani oggi
confidiamo
[Musica]
grid
[Applauso]
iniziamo del tango con i glitter questi
glitter azzurri del diritto al cibo come
seal hanno il problema di lardo è
compatto accesso il più primo
ingrediente i clip non ero mai verso il
glitter come il primo ingrediente
eccoli qua teniamola tutto per il
secondo ingrediente 21
[Risate]
[Musica]
allora mettete che ferma tu qua però per
fermare su play ma si è fermata su miele
come cavolo si no
andiamo ad aggiungere il miele i click
come diventano miele con i click
ma c è qui che sembra che sono diventati
veri male notte che strano sembra miele
che per otto berto ingrediente no al
detersivo per i tassisti è fermato al
detersivo per piatti e detto no perché
avete visto che si stava per fermare
nuovamente a miele qui vado ad
aggiungere queste due testi con per
piatti a miele e p3
tra l'altro gli ingredienti che si sono
qua non ho ancora se stato quali
funzionano e quali non funzionano
paredes live set e in irlanda sapevo
tutti quelli che possiamo limitare
questi non è evidente che non funzionano
comunque ecco qua il composto finora e
tipo verde giallo e non diventi lo
sapete che a me piace scelto gli inferni
comunque quattro ingressi al parco vero
si guardi cliente
[Musica]
oddio cioè si è bloccato e bloccato nel
mezzo praticamente track sapone è molto
meglio la stanghetta mossa qua sopra
allora ritiro la ruota lato come un urlo
perché stavamo per decidere io e
alimenti rollato quanto sembri quasi
[Risate]
[Musica]
bari e detersivo nuovamente detersivo
per piatti banalmente neanche detersivo
per piatti sperone anche capitale dopo
così possiamo provare ad addensare lo
però con cosa cavolo lo attendiamo un
motto ben retto la maledizione degli
stein verdi perché con lo spaccio queste
challenge che le cose sono anche su
carta ma sempre le ricordate un po che
il colore questo è verde incredibile
all'essere un po celeste adesso è
diventato bene non è possibile sembra
assurdo ingrediente
[Musica]
[Risate]
ho detto prima di metter primo qualche
ottima è finito su palline
ecco cuore aggiungiamo le palline al
detersivo per piatti killer che ci porti
a quelle date un po sì ma questo slime
carta che con i glitter superbello tendo
ingrediente
[Musica]
[Risate]
non si può mancare
[Musica]
felice non volete su detersivo piatti
non ci posso credere ha notato che in
faccia dott.sa polacco ridente stiamo
per piatti è la terza volta che capita
perché in realtà questa mela come la mia
maledizione di stalin ferdi perché
ovviamente ora lo slime è ancora più
verde con il detersivo per piatti volta
mi raccomando non ce le hanno
ingrediente verde ingrediente numero 7
ok per fortuna un ingrediente diverso
dal solito e il sapone quindi vado ad
aggiungere e cova il sapone per le mani
memento un po perché almeno questo
sapone rosario ho visto che va a
tollerarlo forse un gran tempo inverter
poi il cliente numero 8 da spremuta
qualcosa di decente
[Risate]
[Musica]
è uscito cioè la pasta quella per fare
anche il battersi ordinamento allora su
lancio di un tweet troppo dopo dovevo
mischia rito con le mani sarà l'acqua
ragazze sarebbero pasta modellabile
quella che si mischia con lo slime
contenti come siro
allora è ancora abbastanza morbida ma
non è morbidissima e quindi prima zio e
degli altri due ingredienti poi il
rischio tutto anche con le mani oggi
dove è una scusa traditi ma non ho mai
fatto noto line dance
ok ragazzi non ingrediente per ultimo
via
[Musica]
fai allora aggiungo la farina di mais
dopo quando andrò mischiato tra mette un
po in mezzo apparirà quindi non vola
dappertutto arriviamo all'ultimo
ingredienti decimo ingrediente braia
volta mi raccomando
dammi qualcosa di che ci stia bene in
questo miscuglio ultimo ingrediente 3
europea glitter e twitter che badano
tale valutarli blu colti magari
contrastano il verde io stavo fino
all'ultimo che uscisse il sale così
almeno poteva dentali detersivo per
piatti babuscio niente devo quindi
mischiare questa poltiglia di roma
ora mi posso vedere bene come dal sito
secondo il quale conto disastro ecco qua
ragazzi vedete allora questi sono i
glitter poi se il detersivo per piatti
tutto verde sotto e poi se il clay co e
mezzo allora io provo a mischiarlo un
momento con la paletta perché se ci
metto subito le mani dentro e diventa
punti
o mio dio perché vedete tutto il terzino
perché altissima tra l'inter e altra
roba basso
super missile è super viscido forse
mischiandolo un po riesco a fare in modo
che non sia più viscido re e affissi
frutto né allora ho aggiunto un po di
farina perché prima ne avevo messo
pochissimo ma la farina in realtà sta
aiutando a farlo solidificare un
pochetto allora siccome era un po e non
riuscivo a stupire cliccarlo tutto ne ho
staccato un pezzo è iniziato a lavorarlo
e guardate si sta formando e anche super
morbido ora ovviamente un continuare ha
mischiato un pochino e mi devo lavare le
mani soprattutto 85 primi mani prima di
lavarmi le mani voglio provare a mettere
le mani qua e vedere se si sta formando
un po sembra che qualcosa si stia forma
però ci vuole un bel po di lavorazione
ancora quindi ci vorrà un po di tempo
il fatto con hitler e senza colla stesse
mi scrivete che non riescono ci vuole un
sacco di pazienza cipolleta pertanto
trans tempo per fare informare ad
esempio questo lo dovrei mischiare per
tantissimo tempo prima di farlo uscire
tutte le forse anche aggiungere un po di
farina
siccome non voglio il video troppo mi
posso vedere l'altro pezzetto sta dalla
parte di via manin faccio vedere come è
diventato un altro pezzetto ragazzi ho
ripulito tutto comprese le mie basali
eccolo qua è diventata una sorta di
pasta però è super morbido sono sorpresa
che è rimasto molto morbido e non si è
indurito troppo sembra un po clusterina
se guardate bene potete vedere i
brillantini e le palline li vedete sono
molto sorpresa che alla fine sia uscito
un qualcosa di decente ed è anche molto
antistress proprio perché è molto
morbido andrà tipo plastilina però molto
più soffice e ha un buon profumo sono
davvero sorpresa che con questi dieci
ingredienti totalmente casuali sia
uscito uno slam senza colla e
incredibile 3
se volete vedere un altro video come
questo in cui faccio lo slime senza
colla con una volta lasciate un bel live
oppure fatemi sapere se volete vedere
uno in cui uso la colla o qualcos'altro
non lo so ditemi voi nei commenti cosa
preferite che fa salire temi tutte le
vostre idee su come posso puntare una
volta e ti farò anche il video sommitale
in cui babbo natale assieme con la rotta
voi l'avete chiesto in tantissima esso
prima stanze però questa posta perché
super morbida
mi raccomando un bel pollice in su e ora
vi lascio qua quattro case linee su cui
potete cliccare se volete vederle mi
altri challenger di te divertenti
meandri della colla cliccate su quella
che preferite e buona visione e mimmo